good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the VIP corner for this press
point with Michel Barnier
chief negotiator for the European
Commission and how many grabbed
Secretary of State before executing
exiting the European Union will have to
short statements and then we have time
for a very limited number of questions
with Shivani I said thank you and good
afternoon to all of you and thank you
very much for your presence
Dominique and I focused on what needs to
be done in our three work streams number
one a backed-up solution for avoiding
our border and the island of Ireland
number two the other outstanding issues
of the withdrew agreement for instance
the protection of existing geographical
indications amongst others three the
political declaration on our future
relationship our teams will sit together
again tomorrow to try and make progress
last week our teams already a discussion
on island of Ireland and Northern
Ireland as you know we need a legally
operational backstop in the withdraw
agreement we must find pragmatic
solutions in line with the commitments
made by Prime Minister May in December
and March and we must be dramatize the
shoe and spell out which controls are
needed where and how this should be done
next time we meet Dominic and I we will
take stock on this work the negotiations
are now entering the final stage we have
agreed that
you and the UK will negotiate
continuously from now on and then we can
I will meet regularly to take stock and
move the negotiations forward decent
return on the principles of the U in
these negotiations are well known and
have been consistent for the last two
years they have been defined by the you
leaders with a great sense of
responsibility for the European project
and integrity of the single market also
the you respect the choices made by the
UK government we can find common ground
based on the new principles and one and
the other and the choices made by the UK
as I said in July we are more far more
advanced in defining that common ground
for foreign policy and security than for
the economic relationship our challenge
for the coming weeks is to try and
define an ambitious partnership between
the UK and the EU a partnership that has
no precedent this partnership has to
respect the single market and the
foundations of the European project and
if this is well understood we can
conclude the negotiations successfully
now I give the floor to Dominica
well Michelle thank you and can I thank
you and your team for hosting us today
we've had a positive set of discussions
which have been very useful on all of
the three main categories of issues the
withdrawal agreement outstanding
separation issues on Northern Ireland
we've reaffirmed our commitment to the
undertakings in the joint report but we
must come up with solutions that are
deliverable for the communities affected
that's the key on the future
relationship we also talk both about the
economic partnership and
where we've made some good progress I
think on the security cooperation there
are still some significant issues to
overcome yes on Northern Ireland I think
we both recognize that but also on the
future relationship and it's important
to view the whole deal as a package we
agreed that we need to step up the
intensity the negotiations as we come
into the final phase and we've agreed to
meet regularly and resolve at the
political level those outstanding issues
that remain under technical
consideration and I'm pleased that with
Michele we've agreed to meet next week I
hope for longer on all of those issues
and I think it's absolutely vital there
are still gaps and we've had an honest
conversation about those equally on our
side we feel we've shown the ambition
the energy and the pragmatism and I know
how committed Michele is to securing a
deal and if we have that ambition that
pragmatism and that energy on both sides
and confident we can reach the agreement
in October thank you very much ok time
will allows for two questions we start
with mark thank you gentlemen
mark Stone from Sky News and mr. Barney
8:00 to you first of all if I may
someone in the UK will listen to what
you just said and they will openly now
say as some already have been saying to
hell with it we leave with no deal
because the EU side is simply not
budging one bit you talk about the
principles being clearly defined for the
past two years and you simply haven't
moved what's your response to that you
don't appear to be budging on the EU
side to what the Brits are saying is the
negotiation and that they have moved for
you mr. Rab a lot in the you a lot of
people in the UK I think will be quite
confused because the prospect of no deal
apparently is now very high some in your
party some of whom are in government are
saying that No Deal is fine that it's um
not something we should be scared of
others are saying that no deal would be
a disaster you say you're not planning
for a deal but on Thursday you are
planning for no deal on Thursday you're
clearly going to plan for no deal what's
the reality how likely is no deal and is
it good or is
it bad can you be honest with the public
and a very quick or final thought for
you mr. Bernier I haven't heard you use
your hillwalking
analogies for quite some time we talked
about walking in the Hills you like
walking in the Hills you talked about a
lot before where are we on this brexit
journey right now captain macho
Montaigne ready for goddess on sofa
Ferris your escape rocket a oh [ __ ] Toby
Agadir Sameach general No Fee paddy
discover to disseminate cotton a
solution solution Monsanto boo you know
did you have Appa shorty no possible the
Pedersen cooperation repressive Oracle a
battle in European why we keep renewable
simple contrary
Dominic III new advances on swattin
respect oh I'm senior great oh I don't
give a penny from this of the precip
sorry Val so the regular set an
ecosystem at the gray the Lord norm
addiction supervision certification in
human ecology Australia perfect no BIA
set ecosystems can you level constraints
all the pre Quran Kitab awesome
don't suppress apply for a steady note
some serious or you can have a user
successfully Kelly max uniquely costly
poor rest
she said yeah Capri
would we deployed the curves represent
common grounds out the guidelines du
conseil hockey so mamada should say per
event such a date that we all know a
white paper for me did you Jesus ever
use my can use it to Josiah's no but
still at the point a goddamn Enoch I've
okay security are you the secret X tell
you on a divorce should shave all ready
point a car cost risk of harm Sentret
ridiculous you let me reduce it refers
Nova Scotia boudoir novelty so like is
don't do the horror so economy y'all
call the point it is a comp a skirt
skewed are white paper I don't
contradict show your attempt one chapter
what a vicar the guidelines you can say
European salute hot wine yeah covariance
by example an obese you free trade
agreement said impose or can move on
Akeno taco well first of all I just
should say that I agree with Michelle
that we need to keep as we climb the
mountain our eyes on the summit and
accentuate the positive and there are
many positive areas where we agree but
of course we've got to close down those
areas of disagreement on the question
you asked me about
No Deal look our actions speak louder
than words we're out here I'm here
seeing Michelle again I should be
returning next week we're going to be
picking up the intensity the
negotiations we agree on that
at the political level we need to
vitalize these talks and get issues out
of technical discussion into political
resolution but of course the responsible
thing for any government to do and
indeed on the EU side to do is to make
sure that we're prepared for all
eventualities from the negotiations
look as you will see when we set out our
plans some of these hair-raising scare
stories are very far from the truth and
I look forward to explain the context on
Thursday but for today the overriding
focus and indeed in the weeks ahead is
trying to get the best feel-good for the
UK for Shabbos careless to pay for
partir de la terre democracy Paul depe
why we need renewal pain Padma's tomato
Shiva fat ricotta Abu a party to say
that madam is deserve yo Calvo - Komodo
demeanor open to tourists Oh seems a
beauty salon occur Parvati mwah Dominic
Dom renewed wale it only protects our
open Kitab oh very monotone droite
anaconda - necessary compressible
DeRogatis Acacio ascetic of the hot red
Ducati Titanic educativa para consider
ministry para la tropa sanic on de
tocqueville and this is no definitive
sollacaro trailer declaration politic
jennifer lisandroni property October
2007 precipitate live in Rome Sabu Cobra
we and unless the Secretary of State
wants to add something well only on the
prospects of a deal look there are three
ingredients ambition on the substance
energy and pragmatism and compromise and
we're committed to that and if it's
match we get a deal it's that simple
facing the probability of heartbreak sit
if you don't agree to something
could you imagine that maybe facing the
big risk of a heartbreak suit to
revision of the decision to say okay
maybe it's for the Brits not the best
thing to stay but the risk and all these
things could happen are even better than
a heartbreak see could you imagine that
you revise this this process certainly
on the UK side know we will be leaving
in March of next year we'll be prepared
for all eventualities from the
negotiations but again we come here and
I come here with renewed commitment and
energy and vim and vigor to put into the
negotiations to get ourselves across the
line beaucoup de polynésie over No Deal
remember acute effects avec vous so
develop a non toxic waste
Sajid blame game colony open cadre no
deal new openness ricotta crostini pass
brain game object to non-compensable
GD de vous ET de la salle des Pres a
commission PolyU
la première conference depress a federal
vocal negotiator que el brexit aha the
Canseco's yo hablo women social economic
finishes techniques ridic
hmmm dick who pursues estimate second
seconds evident the formula Prix kudos
rubrics it's a renewed I'll use a
composite option
monkara impose adoption MC de partido to
vivo yet oprah converse a video coach a
[ __ ] para algo de otaku Susie Castillo
de preparation to tea parties in certain
positive so a new trabajo por
conscription pattern are a few
charitable organization all the name
means a deal may be foreign cover
solution ah soul can do some booty her
fans of Shama vector and a cocky
d'Ivoire respectively developer okay
Brittany glossy lip conceived sorry
candy from the reporter of you I think
we will leave it to you thank you very
much ladies and gentlemen we now have a
handshake float opportunity and then